we can start chen there it is guys i
just want to say that the entire world
has omnichrome and i want to say this
out loud now it's going to be
controversial it's not because i know
what you're going to say and filming
what are you going to say and other
people have said who are way more famous
than us two days ago i just go ahead i'm
sorry brother all right never mind that
no gloria what are we going to say
i wanted to hear what he had to say
to like ruin my where did i like take my
well we just talked about it i want to
know i want to know brian i think
everybody's got omnichrome uh and it's
all good and it's probably the fastest
way to get over the [ __ ] so let's just
all get it phil mickelson had a great uh
i think his instagram tweet he goes hey
i'm not a doctor i don't know don't
don't hate on me because
wouldn't it make sense if everybody just
gets omnicron and we move on past things
so we get hurt immunity because i don't
know i'm not a doctor yeah stone
shepherd said the same thing and he's
[ __ ] literally straight up journalist
so many people i'm tired of talking
about kovacs i'm tired of it but hey
i've known someone to get it twice they
they have this family no no you can get
a variant you apparently you can have
the old variant and you can catch
omnichrome again that's not science
either right the only thing is is the
the the issue with people saying that
twice and the faulty testing the tests
are so [ __ ] faulty
are they are they really are they yeah
yeah yeah really oh big time
yeah there's an issue because he took he
took quite a few yeah
you do that that i do
i had got it with the my homie that got
it
the second time or whatever i had got it
with him the first time when i had
covered uh back in july or whatever and
then he took uh
uh
four of those tests the one you got from
all games they all were positive uh yeah
those one i think he did uh yeah the
long game where you get you get the
green and the purple the uh pink uh
thing yeah are they not good no no how
do we know
the reliability on this trouble really
yeah but if it's a if it's a pink line
um what about them wholesaling now
because i i do think you can i do think
there's some evidence that the omicron
is something you can get twice i i know
you can't get the same variant twice
like there's if you look at cdc there's
literally no evidence of it even though
people were saying with that
everyone's just talking about they have
the sniffles yeah it's like it's like a
cold yeah which is a great thing we've
got the cold which is natural which is
natural during this when i tell you that
i when i tell you that literally i know
like i'm telling you everybody i know
has gotten it so everybody i mean
everyone for real like everybody i know
mickelson said a bath man just let's do
this how was y'all's christmas y'all
have a good christmas well mine was
obliterated because everybody in my
family got sick and my parents
yeah but i i i'm the super spreader
because i what happened to me is i went
i want to see everybody you're not a
superstar because you didn't have it
dude no but i went and i was exposed to
my nephew
he had it and then i was exposed to a
couple other people then i went over to
my ex's house with her family my kids
and they all got it no nobody got it
there i mean they're all super spreader
branches
but i got in trouble because apparently
i was they're like you went there and i
was like you don't have it now and then
i you know no i don't have to but so you
don't have that you're not super
stressed you're not a super spreader i'm
not a super spreader i might have had it
before but i don't know you're good i
know i was sick for two weeks
you had 19 days no no i'm talking about
i was recently originally sick and then
my girl was sick
she took a test were you and she had it
there was a little pink line there
oh really the in-home test yeah but i
but but i didn't i was negative so i
took a test and i was negative but
that's a home test
and that was after i was you know after
i was sick but i was still a little
sniffly yeah and i took the i took just
to see and i was negative so
well what'd you do for christmas dude my
girl and i we went to uh universal
studios they're open on christmas oh
that's dope yeah chris cause christmas
day for me i was miserable kids that was
not for her oh you didn't like
i'm not i'm not a music park fan at all
was it packed though uh
i don't even it was good size yeah it
was a lot of people
actually really liked it yeah it was
pretty packed she loved it she had the
time of her life that's that's all that
mattered to me you don't like going on
rides and [ __ ] i just don't i don't care
i get sick you know what that
transformer ride was actually pretty
cool one's fun huh that one was like the
best one i know i used to be able to
ride i was shocked it's really dope i
thought i was like me too
during halloween i was like i don't want
guns but do you
get sick on rides yeah i can't do i i i
do i never use the toasters i never used
to think
it's it depends on the roller coaster if
it's like one of those ones that's like
dropping it i'm fine with that it's when
they turn and yeah that's me they lose
but it's like now i got to take a pill
yeah i guess i guess it throws off your
inner ear for some people like oh brian
i mean
i had to go behind i had to go behind
the ride and my there my kids were like
is he going to throw up
and then uh
again because i didn't ask for any gifts
like i'll invite you over from menudo i
know
you're running away from christmas eve
you don't eat menudo yeah do you know
what menudo is sure it's the stomach
line of cows
it's also a group from the 80s yep ricky
martin was in it
ricky martin was in it
damn
look at you all right brian no i'm not
talking about the ricky martin group in
the 80s i wish they came over i bet you
it's just not menudo i think you're
messing up the name of it no i promise
that band's named after this that
noodles like manuda is a soup with with
cow intestine like oh yeah so you don't
know about that yeah yeah yeah
cow stomach lining
and then a tendon i told my guy i go i
work too hard make too much for you see
like
you're not mexican
we can toss [ __ ] beef and [ __ ] the
attachments all they did made is soup
yes
they made menudo
soleil i was [ __ ] star
domino pizzas on christmas i was
starving i'm like i'm a grown man i
can't eat soup man dude i can't eat just
[ __ ] soup
that's right that's all it is too the
italians have the stomach the inside of
the stomach and you you put it you mix
it in the stew that was disgusting my
mother eats it i'm like i can't eat
yeah that's the stomach [ __ ] you that's
what they mean on christmas i didn't
i didn't eat
i didn't i refuse to eat i'm not eating
that people love it man i was like i'm a
grown man i can't i can't sue can we
whiten up a little on christmas there's
no [ __ ] turkey
you're weighing up a little there's no
time to look over my sons eating them
like put that [ __ ] down no turkey or ham
nothing dude just oh
soup dude damn but then dominos came
flying to the rescue four large pizzas
for your boy oh so when you wake up you
got big pots on that stove of stewing
and then they made uh sopas where the
[ __ ] they that's the soup
it is it is tough to just eat that and
that's it and then you're like i'm like
this is what we're doing
right no no corn no pizzoli no
no no you're thinking
oh it's always like a uh sorry i do a
white or red broth okay and then there's
like beef in it and then uh yeah but i
think is that the large corn kernel
oh yeah yeah they're all good
yeah and they take that's corn they take
tortillas and put it where are you
starving yeah start with marvin you're
like hey i'm all set on this man yeah
whiten up a little bit guys you're
getting you get you're gonna get you're
not a gift guy no i hate guessing i know
i love like listen if you have kids
christmas is a big deal if you don't
have kids let's go there's no [ __ ]
that's dope for kids oh he woke up at 5
00 a.m
oh there you go they were ready
oh yeah you got to go of course oh
brilliant
tv
yeah oh bry made chocolate chip cookies
the way he likes them the toll house
ones you know with the butter and the he
didn't make them all that yeah that's a
toll house bro
yeah you just pulled them [ __ ] off
the dough with the the no i just added
that scratch i mean
why'd you say house because you take the
tow house to the toilet recipe is two
sticks of butter
two eggs uh well i do a half a half a
cup of but it's usually three quarters
of a cup of brown sugar white sugar then
i'll extract you you you mix that up how
many cookies do you mix that up then you
add
you know you add flour but the problem
is here's the problem with me what ma'am
too big i'm not a dessert guy
i'll eat the whole [ __ ] i'll eat all
the cookies
first of all i'll eat all the dough then
i get sick then i cook them and then i
eat those yeah i love it i get all
[ __ ] up you know you can there's a
store at the mall where you just get
cookie dough
that is basically oh i love it i love
cookie dough cookies
no papa i can't talk nothing we had
desserts all over the place oh my teeth
we gotta get some
or not or not also my boy mike goes hey
no bobby you guys listen to this let's
get some shots in your mouth no you guys
don't know what the [ __ ] you're talking
about you're a doctor i don't know my
teeth are all right are they oh listen
hold on let me hear his dick right yeah
no no i need to see the dentist but
listen it's my boy mike you know the
head of thick boy productions
mike goes dude i'm listening to finding
the kid you guys are so [ __ ]
frustrated he goes how do you not see
the billboards around town that it's a
density that puts you to sleep so you
don't deal with any of the paint oh yeah
send me the link yeah daddy's going
there that's fine i wake up boom
they put you to this they might play
with my dick i don't care don't they fix
my teeth it's a long process just get
your [ __ ] just hey just get some
novocaine oh [ __ ] i know a guy that gets
uh put under for teeth cleaning i get it
down
if you want to go to sleep i get it
i really don't
huh i don't i don't know that you want
to though bubba i think well i'm going
to ask him how bad is it first he's like
dude it's just a few caps and you're in
and out then i'm like all right let's
get it done go go he's like dude it's a
big deal
go to my guy there's no pain bubba he's
really good
he's been doing it for too long he's
been doing it for a [ __ ] time yeah
and my thing is my girl set me up with
an appointment uh last week i was just a
bit i'm swamped yeah well you're like i
can't go this week because i can't say i
can't make fun of you for not wanting
pain because i won't get a flu shot i
don't like it it hurts
i'm already nervous about our tough
mudder uh by the way i got my phone
you're still down so hunter mcintyre who
is the eight-time world champion yeah uh
a tough mudder yeah we we might want to
have mon we'll just ask him questions
about the tough mudder yeah i'm talking
to him uh i'm talking about today just
he's just a really colorful dude he's
gonna run with us yeah well he will he
or he's probably doing he's there's two
different he's the best he's in the he's
not running one no wait i thought we i
thought it wasn't a competition
yeah well no it's exactly what i'm
saying there's people that start earlier
that do it for like a living yeah we're
not with them no we're [ __ ] eating
tamales and priscilla and yeah and
climbed up the middle yeah yeah yeah oh
no but i mean i'll like
be fun to ask him questions
you know what do you know what the exact
events are for for uh nah man you have
too many questions just a good time you
know and it's not that serious all right
here's the events dude yeah here's
events
water mud got it climb a rope yeah run
is it cold get shot i don't know what
the temps can get also it says la now
this is this isn't my marketing this is
tough mudder they're like la you look it
up it's right outside [ __ ] san diego
dude it's [ __ ] it's not l.a it's
orange county anything yeah you could
say in l.a yeah even my fans like dude i
don't see that one i was like yeah lake
elsinore like hey dumbass that's like a
lake or something yeah it's gonna be
kind of late i'm actually excited about
it it's so fun yeah
my future you don't want to know all the
events i'm telling you the best part is
going into it just having no idea what
you're signing up for that's what i mean
it's so much fun i don't want to know
like you're trying to surprise
i'm excited you're still on board yeah
it'd be great to do it as a group i
can't you know i know [ __ ] casey's in
are you yeah cat's
not in are we thinking about it
come on okay not really my running is
the mud the cold
it's okay i accept that i accept that
what do you think bro
yeah what am i gonna do wear a bracelet
how many how many of us are there's
going to be me at the three of us three
of us more than that and casey more than
that okay people you know yeah us
yeah some of them probably top gentlemen
way larger than this okay yeah i would
assume so we're all going to say yeah
we're going as a crew in our group yeah
so yeah but we break up sign up for a
thick boy
you don't break up in anything man it's
like a thousand people all running at
once okay and you're just with you i
thought you have to help each other over
the yeah
well i could be like [ __ ] see ya and
then do my own thing but we just stick
together yeah yeah like mark could dust
all of us but we all stick together mark
harley he moved of course
with that size yeah he moved for ten
more oh yeah mark get the [ __ ] out of
here why wouldn't he yeah why wouldn't
he i've never seen a bodybuilder with
that kind of muscle mass be able to do
that
in a heart wow like though those buttery
bros could have finished but we're all
stuck together because it's funner dude
that's not that serious dude yeah yeah
we're not taking this seriously no when
you get done there's all these food
trucks there's whiskey there's these
huge hot dogs covered in bacon and [ __ ]
right yeah you're covered in mud great
shower together shower yeah there's a
shower shower all right yeah yeah y'all
can do this like back in high school man
the lockers i can't wait there's a
trough where you just you and i
hey chappelle you ain't touching me no
but at least i could see oh yeah we're
finally gonna see it no yeah yeah i'll
start when i get home
[Applause]
you know what
so i can get off this dig subject i had
a great time with y'all hollywood improv
oh that's right we haven't been here
since then how much fun was that bro it
felt like the old days didn't it oh my
god
that was [ __ ] electric so much fun
that was the old insane i love it
that was great i know what you're saying
and racist sam
you know you know what sam is a 90s
comic that is trapped in a 90s bubble
he's the greatest he's the last of the
true
we call sam the last of the true the
last of the he is a [ __ ] monster the
last one hilarious
hey they call me smile great shots
great shots great crowd
so carol's amazing
sam brings
you know sam you know he's he well boy
sam's like hey uh guys give to uh please
donate to uh this next comic please
don't tell me uh david lucas dave lucas
is uh go fund me after he dies of
diabetes
he's overweight
we're like
you and i were laughing we were laughing
so hard i don't have that hard now i
know yeah did david get him though no no
no no david heard it david oh david here
we were laughing brandon and i and then
we started laughing in the middle of a
set too after that just i just couldn't
believe it it just seems such a [ __ ] the
way he did it was so like nonchalant
guys give to this dude yeah i love this
guy you know he crushes it one of my
favorite comics make sure you donate to
his gofundme when he passed away from
diabetes
i was like
he called me a power bottom he goes this
guy he calls
he said i was black i was like i'll take
it yeah yeah he's nice a little dicey
he's a night he's that old school he's
always big and blacker yeah big and
black or something like that but i was
like yeah deep space
face yeah
which is the most racist hilarious [ __ ]
i've ever heard about
i was like i don't even think i've heard
that one before
well sam will just come up with [ __ ] i
know i don't know
he's a watcher yeah another one if you
didn't get tasty i told you don't
complain january 5th it's another
wednesday night 8pm same crew and a very
special guest that's at the hollywood
improv and that is january january 5th
one show only 8 p.m
can't wait this week we're in florida
man okay you're ready for that track oh
yeah
thursday friday saturday bringing the
new years with your thick friend fort
lauderdale florida i got oklahoma city
come see me i'm jealous that's a nice
that's a nice flight that's a nice
flight yeah it's a great club yeah i'm
in [ __ ] i can't wait till you meet
that bodyguard oh he's best he's the
best i don't know his name you can't
miss him don't worry you know exactly
who he is sounds like giant man giant
man he's a big dude like mohawk yeah
okay
oh and he's he's type he talks about all
the [ __ ] he's on it like it went on deck
on right it looked like i'm taking man
look at that look at that girl loved it
and then he does the merch we didn't ask
him to do it we're doing merch we saw
because so hot when we're there yeah so
we only had hoodies left we had like 150
hoodies left saw those shirts the first
night you know i don't know what i'm
gonna do so he cuts the sleeves off the
hoodie puts on you want to be like brand
shot brand shot wear it like this go
ahead get your hoodie get sleeveless
sold out
go ahead and get your hoodie cut this
layla you want to be like bringing kills
he talks
[Music]
he's the best he's the best i said dude
i get to like kevin hart level i'm
hiring you to come on the road with me
all the time that's a good guy oh he's
the best yeah you want a good guy like
that yeah that's my girl there you go
man look at her test man go ahead look
at her man look at her man she's the
bartender
man that's a good character
i like the way you're doing that she
won't let him be on
look at that look at that body leave
them trapped man they're looking at them
traps man he was jazz
he's still he's a big believer in
juicing oh yeah he's oh basically
he's he's old school like
he's just a regular he's a reckless boy
wow and then someone like said something
they weren't even heckling he said i
went and took that guy out roughed him
up a little bit for you man
hey
yeah i took care of me he won't be back
don't worry about him oh yeah he was on
it with hector
he was on it and so he's a he's a he's
an oklahoma boy yeah yeah oh yeah
rednecky or what i don't know
it's not out here more more like a biker
club why yeah
i'd say more of that
yeah jacked yeah yeah big dude oh boy
he's the best but quick with a heckler
oh yeah he tapping right on just hey
yeah i'm not going to have to tell you
again we have bronze yeah we got yep
okay again
we got probably spent some time maybe
behind bars you know
i would
i wouldn't be shocked
i wouldn't be sure you know what that
bricktown has the best chicken wings
dude oh what they call the new orleans
mix or something like that yeah
something like that gosh
across the street they have a seafood
restaurant that's fantastic like
classical yeah what was the restaurant
like jambalaya like occasionally
i just like saying
don't want to go to when you're there is
where that oklahoma city bombing would
happen so sad that'll ruin your day yeah
where they where they killed a bunch of
kids in that daycare yeah
so sad yeah well [ __ ] you like soon as
you walk up and like you get in the
middle it's just
heavy that'll [ __ ] up your day
i know it's like we got to do shows at
night with like hey man you're my
brother shout out man i'm like bro i'm
i'm in front of you who was that
yeah i'm not doing that i'm not gonna
post things like go ahead and say what's
up with my friend ma'am like bro this
ain't the spoon who was that i forget
mark oh that's right that was mark was
like hey man say what's up my brother
man i'm like dude i'm not here yeah it
was like give him a shout out i'm like
dude there's like this is his brother's
birthday yeah
my brother's a big fan he's a brother
tell him everybody
i can't do that during the morning oh
it's tough and then we had to do shows
that night
yeah
yeah i'm so jealous dude hopefully
florida's funny on
gonna love florida i mean i don't think
don't don't sleep on fort lauderdale's
amazing yeah the crowds are incredible
and uh that's a new club that's a new
beautiful club there's a whole enclosure
yeah santino did the stefano
you're in a casino there's a casino
there so it's i believe it's a native
american no it's outside of that i think
is it i think it's they said that they
have a joke
building yeah all new buildings yeah
they built the florida casino they tore
everything down and rebuilt it i
remember hey you know what's the new
spot in l.a it has to be the improv's
kind of taken over dude 100 percent that
green room and the 5th place
as drake says so many vibes
[ __ ] loved it i agree i agree it was
so much fun uh yeah so much [ __ ] fun
dania yeah
dania beach yeah it's casino oh you're
right yep
yep it's wait is it a casino uh-huh hold
on no that's not here but
no no there's a casino and then you go
outside to an outdoor mall and yeah it's
an outdoor mall that's exactly where the
old improv was it's great that's kind of
like
it's [ __ ] happening you're going to
love it it's a complete party you're
going to love it it's it's one of the
it's always been one of my favorites
[Music]
florida has really good clothes i think
you're gonna i predict you're gonna
[ __ ] love that well i was dreading
going to naples and that's one of my
favorite clubs oh it's great the
off-the-hook club it's great i loved it
well eric naples erica is good virgina
makes it amazing
that [ __ ] is great have you guys
done the orlando improv and stuff like
that yeah yeah i've never done that is
that what you know atlanta is a little
tough it's oh it is is it is it town
it's disney you know oh got it
my favorite city there is uh tampa ebor
like i love that theater temple is in
tampa tampa is great awesome oh yeah you
do tampa improv yes yes it's basically a
little theater though
i'm a miami fort lauderdale guy
ultimately but yeah we'll see i'm not
done fort lauderdale oh i like florida
though oh you're going to love it bubba
you're great i like florida miami was
popping so fort lauderdale was always my
number one
yeah people love everything like of of
the greatest crowds the greatest
experiences yep fort lauderdale
yeah what's north florida what's in
northwest i guess jackson jacksonville
north jacksonville's
jackson is tough it is
i mean if you it sounds like it could be
lit there
cat cat what do you think ken williams
did a special there no i yeah i know
that sure um
one thing there's nothing i don't know
where you're going
yeah really yeah it's not yeah yeah i
had a tough day fred ders from
jacksonville i think sure sure had a
huge drug from um
yeah
yeah is it orlando and i guess orlando
is not really
normal is tough because it's just
disneyland people are there just for do
like the locals aren't coming it's a
weird market yeah there's nowhere to go
i don't i'm not crazy this is northgen
yes you got gainesville where the
university of florida is at less than
jake's from gainesville and by the way
covet kind of killed orlando that whole
that whole area where the uh
the club is it's just incredible however
they shut down
really because disney world didn't shut
down at all yeah they refused to wait
yeah it didn't did it no yeah no my girl
went with this we were invited because
there's nothing covered killed uh so
many of those restaurants their business
it used to be because they never locked
down that didn't make sense right now in
jacksonville you know what you know what
it was it's people weren't flying
the tourists weren't flying that's right
and they rely on tournaments that's what
it was money so they exactly it was not
they didn't shut down because like new
south wales
they shut down because there's no
tourist attractions right that's exactly
right yeah well you know so so uh
the holiday madness where all the
flights were being delayed and canceled
yeah it wasn't weather you know there's
so many people coming down with you yeah
no one said it was weather they voted
everybody was like i got it too now so
yeah you can be in the same room there's
no question that [ __ ] is so contagious
it's hilarious it's good though it means
towards the end of the virus man this is
what they mute and it's it's a real mild
weak you know once
yeah you get it by breathing yeah
what can you do dude i help my uh
neighbors carry their tree into their uh
apartment you're a better guy than me i
would not do that bruh
they bought me new the newest airpods
and a freaking uh the thing where you
yell at it
uh
alexa wow for carrying in the thing yeah
did they buy her was it a gift they
regifted you think oh that's a very good
question hey i'd like to add some very
i'd like to
but also full circle got it that's fair
awesome that's what you guys would live
in the truth and that's a very lab like
oh thank you thank you thank you so i
was saying to myself what great people
there and then he said do you think they
repackaged yeah and i'm gonna put all my
money on that can't you who's gonna give
up the news because they already have it
they already have it like they already
have their products and alexa like you
think so too they're like we don't need
another one yeah it's still a nice gift
okay somebody got double gifts i
guarantee while you're out there like
[ __ ]
grappling with that tree like hey do you
have those earpods and alexa right like
we already have that yeah
oh
[ __ ] one
hundred percent oh wait what i would do
the exact same thing two people bought
the same gift they were sitting there we
don't need two alexis give it to that
guy who helped us with the truth they
wrapped it up and everything yeah
yeah it's probably already right
yeah god damn yeah they ripped off the
stickers
either way good gift yeah pretty solid
although i don't trust alexa you know
the government listens to alexa oh
my girl's dad tracking me when i say get
that [ __ ] out of my house they listen
and they download the data but man it
can do it is that what it does yeah man
if you kill anybody they're going to
listen back to that thing come on you
can rate you can you can [ __ ] uh
order everything i guess i don't think
they're far ahead no i do know
you can think you can order everything
you just tell her to play music dude how
about today last last
official episode ever below the belt
officially left showtime as of today wow
11 o'clock it's noon wow i know
five years cheers cheers about time to
make the move it's all good yeah
i'm excited man yeah showtime and a lot
of networks have had a bit of a hard
time i mean i feel like you know
showtime's lucky because they have brian
daly and brian daley was my boss there
and he's the guy who sees like man we
can't just bank on tv subscriptions like
we got to move into the digital space
and so they started with me
and then they went to all the smoke the
the biggest nba show on [ __ ] youtube
and then they've branched out so they're
lucky they're brian daly i hope they
realize what they have in brian daley
because he's one step ahead he's like we
can't just bank on tv dude we gotta
figure this out they didn't have a they
had no
foot in the door as far as youtube or
podcast goes they brought me on they're
like this is what we need to do yeah and
then they started hustling a couple of
comics talking about how they did their
special on showtime so the first special
i ever did was showtime
and a lot of comics were like talking
this is three years ago four years ago
they were talking about doing a special
on
on showtime and uh how it just it was
tough because nobody really no room no
well you know for me especially at the
time i'll take what i can get and then
greenland is special i'm all about it
but at the same time too like my demo
1836 they're online dude like they need
access to it so being behind a paywall
or being it doesn't do me any justice
going all right special drops tonight at
9 00 p.m and if you don't see it then
see ya like that's not the way things
are your people know you through youtube
they were trying to do that it's like
nobody's going to tune in like tommy
central is different because they have 9
million subscribers on youtube
they've switched over
they put all their content on youtube
much smarter yeah much smarter oh and
they're they're ig they post a lot of
that you got to be able to leverage
youtube i feel like you have to what do
you say you got to get it to the maxes
yeah they have to that's what i watch on
is youtube is there it's like but also
like yeah like if you wanted to go viral
like i can't download a link to showtime
and send to my buddies like hey make
sure you you know pay for a subscription
watch my special wouldn't you also want
to say wouldn't you also say the same
thing as as big as netflix is
just because you have a special on
netflix doesn't necessarily unless they
feature it doesn't necessarily mean even
if they feature it and that what do you
mean even if they feed you
it's rare
like if they give it a push
yeah i have a friend who had a meeting
with them and uh
they're pulling back on specials because
they greenlit 600 and they're not gonna
and even on their chappelle special it
got so much attention but because of the
transgender stuff it doesn't mean that
equaled views so even though they forked
out whatever 30 million chappelle
they're not getting a return on it so
they're pulling back on specials if i
told you the amount of people they've
turned down for specials it would blow
your mind i i bet you told me you
already told me yeah i told you in a
business mind and not a business people
aren't going what they realize are
like let's say you have a huge podcast
even though you're a beast of comedian
it's not translating though so those
podcast listeners aren't going to
netflix to watch specials wow and they
realize that years after i wonder it's
not the same demo it's like it's like
when you get like an actor like a famous
person because i'm gonna do a podcast
well dude you're famous from [ __ ]
x-men the podcast listeners aren't
that's not the demo that's someone
interesting
but also they think that just because
they have a name in hollywood they can
come over and do podcasting and it's
just not the same language i remember
when rogan stopped having actors on like
we were talking about that we don't have
actors no and we same thing was like
well we tried that's like bro you're
playing a [ __ ] character right now
yeah like give us the truth remember we
had that booker i'm fighting the kid
yeah like this guy's from blackish yeah
remember that we're like what's up dude
and it'd be like oh man it wasn't yeah
it was tough they just do interviews
weird or not even necessarily they do it
like they do it like tonight
they do it
but those are all pre like they already
have those questions but there's not
there's nothing real they're also actors
it's not that interesting no you don't
want you i don't want to talk about
making movies not that interesting to me
yeah yeah unless you're on film buff but
i'm i'm not that interested in your
experience i mean have you had a really
famous actor who's been doing movies
their whole life you have meryl streep
or morgan free so you want you want to
do that you wouldn't want to sit down
with them
if you had samuel jackson he dropped
some stories or like sylvester stallone
arnold schwarzenegger
guys who have lived a bunch of lives
great guys but that's rare and will
smith would be fantastic yeah sure jared
leto yeah jared i don't know maybe maybe
maybe jared or maybe not maybe you know
judd little vegan for 30 years yeah you
see his ebook
toby
he's been a vegan for that long do you
see him with his shirt off
he uh they used to tour together who's
toby my boy toby from a mutual friend
and i'm just fine about this now yeah
you have a direct
pathway to jared leto and you just tell
me now dude yeah bring up did you see
him at 50
it's unreal go ahead and bring him up
again now did i watch my mexican family
so vegan did i watch my mexican family
forced to watch
30 seconds to mars mars live in bang
bangladesh yeah i did you did and that
boy can fly so crazy how is he how is he
50 or that how does he look like that
it's unreal
he looks better than i take it easy bro
take it easy that's better than
everybody in this room look at his hair
and look at his [ __ ] look at that
picture
so he's been a vegan his whole life dude
he's been a vegan for he said 20 or 30
years because i asked someone like dude
your skin's ridiculous it's all vegan he
was and also sleep and i don't have any
vices because i don't drink i don't do
drugs i sleep and i eat vegan that's my
these he also lives here
and then i also drink blood from hot
girls i was good i was like oh he does
what yeah yeah that's a guy he doesn't
know
right now
all he does is produce
his oh he doesn't he doesn't have any
kids nope
i'm a man but yeah yeah yeah not that
way you know you love him oh he's my
favorite
oh do you like him as an actor oh my god
he's a great the joker
he's phenomenal dude
and god you don't realize how good he
can sing when you hear him acoustic
what
i am now his instagram's a little tough
okay and now also in the new gucci movie
you won't even recognize me so goddamn
good yeah let me see let me see him
there
he's you got to give it up for him look
at this yeah he's just so talented man
who's the actress there is that that's
the lady lady gaga she's supposed to win
the oscar for it too god is she great
too did she did you see that anyone see
it
no cause in theaters i need to wait for
it to come out on hbo or some [ __ ] and
then i'll see it because adam drivers in
it too who i love god damn look at that
shirt
hey
oh my god there's long hair at 50.
you tell me he doesn't look better than
anybody on the screen i see him at a
couple parties and i saw him at a party
um
and he was uh wearing
like this poncho
you know this sort of regal poncho is
just walking around i was like all right
he made these boots look cool on this uh
youtube thing he was at the last fight
oh yeah yeah he was an artist yeah yeah
we made fun of him he's always had
amazing style man yeah i mean he's
always he was the face of gucci for
god's sakes you know how hard that is
damn
i didn't know that i got a proud actor
too yeah he's always loved uh he's a
creature he's just a creature man he's a
[ __ ] creature you know you grew up
famous you grew up in la and you just
you just march it to a different drum
probably a weird dude let's be honest
you don't want to meet your hair
because i can tell by his by his
instagram probably i'd meet him and it'd
be heartbreaking he's very happy with it
oh he's very happy toby says he's cool
really yeah he's a very happy guy with
his look that's all cool yeah and that's
all good but um yeah i i look at his
eyes though when you've got blue eyes
like that you know how many girls he's
[ __ ]
probably insane all of them well all of
them
just a glass of red wine i'm like just
us like like
sure i i say what do you want me to wear
i'm going to say this and i really go do
you call me daddy you would yeah no i
really go
really i'm going to say this and you
don't you don't [ __ ] you don't [ __ ] with
like anything of that nature now i'd go
right over i'm going gonna say this i'm
being 100 percent serious let's hear it
you've got everything
you would he would have you over
if you got a little drunk
and you were laughing
yeah watch this yeah this is all he did
was hey this isn't a regime and you go
like this you go and he goes hey this is
weird but i'm gonna kiss you and you go
ah [ __ ] it
i don't you're not you're not gay but i
think you would be you'd feel way
awkward to not do it you might giggle
yeah and you do it you're not gonna do
anything more but you might you'd you
might go in there you'd go in there yeah
no you'd have a gay experience with them
and it's fine yeah
it'd be weird and you'd keep it to
yourself and you wouldn't want to talk
about it i'd get it out of you yeah look
at that though
look at that what a strange cat he is
he's a strange creature in a great way
what was that drug movie he was in with
marlon wayne's
oh my god that technically i'm talking
about it's such a great movie god that's
a great it was a dru they were like drug
addicts oh dude that's
darren you'd wreck him first yeah
this movie and uh
and jennifer connolly they were like and
they were not i forgot that yeah
remember that yes dude and he has to
have his arm cut off remember how good
he was in that oh dude he killed that
bubba oh yeah oh yeah
i didn't want you guys to recap it from
me i haven't seen it you haven't seen
him
oh you knew oh you hey i just hate i
hate when people go yeah
it might be a little dated now but at
the time it was amazing
i mean that probably still holds up dude
you'd really like it you should see it
it's one of his best pieces i like
marlon wayne's too yeah he's crazy too
he's been in the game for a minute
marlon
i think i think he has a new special out
too i think yeah that dropped back in
like august yeah he's so good in that
marlin oh yeah 100 percent he can act
man i forgot about that movie dude
requiem yeah dream great movie
great great movie darren aronofsky cat
what'd you do for christmas
well i was supposed to go back to san
jose but i wasn't feeling well i tested
a few times for covid all turned up
negative but i stayed home anyways
uh just to be safe just to be safe i
have a lot of old people my family
didn't want to go see
i think i got it from lax though
i came back from uh aspen the week
before all right and that's like i felt
it like last week
by the way you're so right about
colorado being like the most beautiful
state ever nice it's so [ __ ] nice you
guys do an aspect i felt so [ __ ] poor
did you flatten them when asked asked so
[ __ ] aware
is far into the mountains and where was
in aspen though cat uh i wanted to see
this now
i had never uh been anywhere
yeah stevie we brought butters too oh my
god butters was [ __ ] vicious while he
was there why was he so mad um i think
he was overwhelmed by the amount of
people
that was just kind of like walking in
and out because he went to a very
dog-friendly hotel yeah so there are a
lot of dogs there was a saint bernard
literally my size just roaming around
the halls
that looks it's a beast did you fly into
beautiful dia and then drive to aspen uh
no i flew in directly to aspen oh do you
no
no skiing
no i didn't get to ski stevie snowboards
or some [ __ ] right yeah he's
snowboarding
next time i would love to go
snowboarding but i'm not very good at it
it's not something you try out you gotta
yeah steve you'll sleep huh uh stevie
will sleep yeah he'll take his 12 hours
yeah
yeah
lots of naps tv lots gonna wrap it up
too stevial stevie is not afraid to
sleep a good solid 11 hours or 12
sometimes and then take himself a nice
good one-hour nap yeah but it's just
because he's aspen's nice though yeah
aspen is so [ __ ] nice a lot of whites
a lot of whites
a lot of people looking not in like a
weird like racist way but like very like
huh there's an asian person yeah they
probably thought you created an app or
something yeah i think it's just one of
those things where like
every time we sat down at a restaurant i
can feel someone looking at me from afar
and every now and then like i'll do a
scan of room of the room and there's
like an old like white man just kind of
looking over not like an immortal
yeah i think you're awkward or some [ __ ]
you know they can't oh maybe
that's fair that's what it is it's
attracted to you that's fair yeah we're
the old guys like rock hard i think it's
a little bit good that could be a thing
he has this warlock of a wife i was
gonna say that's what you're doing he's
just yeah he's rock car he's like god
damn it
also because i was with stevie the
entire time i was there all the other
asian people all four of them were in
groups of other asian people i was the
one asian person with like a very like
blonde hair blue eyed white guy so it
looked very ruffle some fantastic
stevie's a good looking [ __ ] man
yeah he's a good looking dude and he's a
smart price staring at us
stevie's probably he's highly
intelligent oh my god stevie could have
gotten a sugar daddy in aspen so fast if
you wanted to sugar daddy or sugar mama
both either one either one no stevia i
want to put it past stevie's very smart
and very good looking he's very
charismatic you can't not love big dick
fat ass yeah that's the thing you cannot
got everything covered yeah
sugar dad would be easy man
brian's getting all serious i'm trying
to make it funny yeah
yeah we all love stevie man you know
he would get it he would get a uh yeah
there you go he could make a lot of
money yeah just with that big dick oh
yeah oh yeah
just
melting that thing
i don't see no aspen no you're not just
milking that i think that thing that
thing's [ __ ]
big have you seen it [ __ ] it yeah
how have you seen it look at this thing
is working with a piece too i'm very
impressed with his dick chris is coming
on chris will be on here because coming
on uh the fight campaign too january
22nd can't wait he's coming out here how
do you see his thing like you just be
seeing dingleton show me a picture of it
yeah he sent me a pic of it yeah he's
very impressed if you got a big dick i
mean show it around it's like having a
ferrari man you want to show your buddy
he's a he's a big good-looking fella
with a piece on him don't kid yourself
three kids too he's got three now yeah
just had another one jesus
latino mama
pumping them kids out jim what'd you do
for christmas
uh parents house with my girl and then
our friends
the whole time or some [ __ ] no
no they're cool they got their boosters
too
yeah
papa shoves out here now and he made
sure everybody's vaccinated and yeah
he's he's
he's out here right now he just landed
yeah how was it 12 yeah
my dad's 81 and he just is not careful
enough he just has never been here he
doesn't give a [ __ ] it's unbelievable
man he's going where he wants having
people over all the time i'm like
haven't caught anything sure hasn't and
he's two he's a viewer you or he's two
six zero and yeah if he gets rid of that
might be tough
i said that i'll be counting all the
women in my family my mother and my
sister they're all hysterical they're
like he's gonna get out he's got
comorbidities and he's like blah blah
blah where are we going to eat you know
it's unbelievable he doesn't care good
for him just does not give a [ __ ]
sometimes you just got to live your life
i've never seen anything like that yeah
you don't want to live the last years of
your life in a lockdown well he tried
you know
when he when he saw me when the bad one
was going around and before they had a
vaccination mother original i didn't
[ __ ] go near him and he goes hey oh
man he came over to hug me or shake my
hand i go no i'm not i'm not i'm not
hugging you i don't want to get close to
you and he goes you know what he said oh
you're one of those
i'm not thinking about that he goes
oh you're one of them i'm like dude you
can die what the [ __ ] are you saying
you're 80 and you're not
you know
i mean he's 80. he probably he's just
like you wanna live the last few years
of your life
he's hilarious that way
that's funny
yeah i don't give a [ __ ]
yeah older people you gotta you know
what it's like
[Laughter]
all right chin what do you got
all right
whoa
what
after some crazy buzzing real quick but
it's gone now oh all right
here we go so there is a tick tock going
viral right now because a woman a woman
claims that she was disinvited from one
of her best friend's wedding as a
bridesmaid have you seen it because she
looked too good in the dress fair point
and a lot of people are saying that this
is [ __ ] want just so she could
postpone
brandon she is gorgeous she's
straightforward absolutely gorgeous
uh but people are thinking this is a lie
that she got disinvited because she
looks too good because one the bride
picked out the dress ahead of time to if
your friend looks like this you know
she's going to be like you don't know
she's exactly everywhere yeah but she
might invite her and then be like holy
[ __ ] oh she's not believing
she always looks like this is a girl
that was supposed to be a bridesmaid
it's not like a regular guess that you
didn't know she was gonna turn up
looking like a [ __ ] victoria's secret
model you knew this the entire time you
guys were friends
so people are speculating that she
probably did something else that got her
kicked out of the wedding she ended up
posting a bunch of these photos and she
went viral
yeah rightfully yeah she's gorgeous
yeah
yeah i'll move her into my house and i
don't even know her that's that's where
you know
i'll donate to her gofundme i'll move
her into my house it's like you know
where do you need a place and we'll see
what happens but i'm willing to roll the
dice here you might be a [ __ ] and i'll
put up with that for about five ten
years
[Music]
she chose for me
my close friend uninvited me now that's
very strange though
still took some fire pics in it though
that's uh what she's claiming we don't
know who the friend is so this is all
like an allegedly look i can see a girl
saying that i'm going to see a girl
going you know what i just can't do it
which is so weird to me but i can and
you think i can absolutely see it the
only thing is this is on tick tock where
a lot of people make up things to go
viral
so it's kind of it's one of those things
where i don't know she's probably she
looks she i'm looking at her tic toc now
she looks pretty thirsty for likes too
yeah
that's what i'm saying now she's like
capitalizing on it either she might
either raise it either way gorgeous
209 000. she's from germany too yeah i
think prior to this she had a few
thousand followers
so she definitely blew up since this
tick tock went viral but she always
looked good though look at these photos
right here yeah let me ask you guys this
how much of this is a filter
i don't think it's a lot of filter i
think she looks like this
like if you she was standing here in
person i don't think yeah they can
filter like curves and all that [ __ ] but
she's a pretty girl man yeah yeah yeah
yeah there's someone saying she's been
like this since jump yeah that's that's
crazy
looks like she went to the same doctor
as aeronaut grande huh
she does is she not all natural
no no i don't i don't think so i had
some work done on the face lips but
still still i don't know great work yeah
that doctor is fantastic
yeah good for her what else you got um
ariana grande's had to work done oh uh
yeah she's son watching on sam and cat
yeah
she's on nickelodeon she's had some
plastic surgery done throughout the
years but as of recess she got a nose
job and then she stopped tanning a lot
so a lot of people now are saying that
she went from black fishing to looking
asian which i don't see the asian part
but because so so there's this uh
[ __ ] youtube thing where they take
out all the music and you just hear them
singing when they're singing
have you seen this thing where you can
hear just the vocals on famous singers
and then some not so famous singers and
you listen to all of them and they're
all amazing and then you hear that
[ __ ] woman saying she's getting
[ __ ] oh she's actually ariana grande
used to be on broadway yeah she was a
broadway like she's before before
she i don't know yeah auditioned for
that role on nickelodeon in order to
create a fan base for her music career
and as soon as she her music popped off
she left yeah wow yeah shouts out you
see her on that sam and catcher my son
it's his favorite show what is that well
sam and kat on nickelodeon he loves it
on netflix and he'll watch like you see
her in the first episodes and she's
completely different looking she's
different she sounds different bigger
face everything that's weird yeah her
original start was on the show victoria
she looked different
not a bad thing yeah she loves that's
why i watch her victorious yeah victoria
she's very she's like second fiddle on
victories
yeah like second or third she wasn't the
main star but the biggest that's her
right there yeah that's what she looks
like i'm victorious but she's also a
young kid yeah yeah yeah so that might
be her face no no bubba knows job come
on the nose yeah the nose job that's
right yeah listen you should be able to
see this because you've had work done
too you know
hey
man
bro in this room you had the most work
done i had my [ __ ] eyelids because i
couldn't see sure sure and then i had
maybe an hour some dots a long time ago
that's it so what we had three
procedures what do you need three three
more than anybody what the [ __ ] three
where are you where are you coming up
with three skin stuff the skin is
there's not a procedure they just they
they freeze like a little marker and
that's for health yeah that's right
that's for health dude well it still
counts as a procedure you've got the
hair transplant and you had your lips
okay
i'm [ __ ] five fifteen years ago at
the time years ago
and it didn't even take man but one one
person said cosmetic surgery should be
okay go to that picture to the right of
that one that you're on game should
recognize the game
that i'm on yeah it's like the three the
three of her like evolution of her i
don't have a problem with it yeah you're
telling me she doesn't look better on
the right so she might have had her nose
i don't know the nose for sure she looks
even more different her nose for sure
photo
um she's at her nose and her lips too or
is that just really good makeup filler
filler uh yeah girls are filling up
who gives a [ __ ] she looks fantastic
she's tiny she was at the comedy store
when she was dating uh pete davidson
yeah she is [ __ ] she's so little so
tiny so little biggest bodyguards in the
world real skinny
yes tiny little thing short
411 maybe
what tiny dude no wonder pete davidson's
big dick looked big in her hand yeah
goddammit
wow
so japan is set to open its very first
esports high school in the spring makes
sense basically it's going to be a
regular high school where kids learn the
normal japanese curriculum and then for
electives you have different options in
gaming to choose from so you can learn
how to
uh program video games you can learn how
to play video games in order to become a
streamer or an esports professional
and it's all happening in japan makes
sense though
gamers make a lot of [ __ ] money i
don't blame them gamers make a lot of
[ __ ] money so much [ __ ] money damn
some of the biggest uh internet creators
are video people who play video games
and people just watch them play the game
i used to watch people play so you did
so you would go to the school take your
regular courses but then also take
courses in-game yeah so instead of like
say taking theater as an elective you
could take uh a gaming course or instead
of sports you'd do gaming yeah i think
they still have a pe curriculum within
their educational system so it's not
like you're neglecting physical training
right now you're going to school to play
video games yeah well you're not going
to school to play no you like learning
like the ins and outs of it
and how to create like create games yeah
it's the same way how we have like
coding school yeah you have this thing
where i realize i'm old i don't even
know what to say about it
i know it's the future i don't know what
to say it's been huge though like
they'll sell out staples they'll sell
out like huge arenas just to watch yeah
they'll have like the gaming convention
and then all the kids live together like
teams they live together like uh like a
[ __ ] navy seal team they have a
nutritionist they have practice oh yeah
like the idea of a gaming nerd isn't the
same thing as you were growing up now
they're like fit good looking in shape
drive crazy cars super successful like
that caught his girlfriend and kick ass
like that ninja kid who
uh we have the same uh business i mean
um
content creator in gaming we have the
same merch guys and i'll go in and see
the amount of merch that kid sells it's
[ __ ] stupid damn that's him mm-hmm i
mean these are the things they deal with
adidas yeah he does and he went to some
uh
platform where they paid him like 50
million just to only play on their
playoffs good for them these kids make
stupid things wait so now
i can't take it what what is he doing
not worth 40 minutes plays video games
he makes ninety five thousand ninety
five thousand a month from streaming on
twitch
and he just plays video games what what
video games
fortnite or whatever he's good at all of
him
yeah he's great at him you have to be
good in order to [ __ ] get paid before
specializing in fortnite halo
[Music]
everybody
he has 24 million subscribers dude yep
shout out to that kid yeah
he had his own shoe with [ __ ] adidas
like yeah i love it yeah they even make
like special chairs for them right yeah
they're special gaming chairs yeah
special gaming shoes that's what i
thought yeah yeah these gamers are the
real deal
yeah you know
those chairs look cool they're cool
that's cool great lumbar sport
it those for a fight companion
like these
not that one that's pretty dope i like
the ones
i don't like because they don't have a
back really
i like to lean back yeah you want
everybody sitting up
that'd be fun mm-hmm not terrible
pricing for a chair these archers are
working what's that no it's only 240.
those are more expensive i don't really
think about it oh these are by a mile so
expensive these yeah how much are these
a few thousand i think something like
that very expensive yeah collectively we
could have went to i think
i don't know i don't remember but it was
expensive
yeah no we could have went to [ __ ]
online only or where the hell it is
with some cool gaming chairs your old
ass saying gaming chair be sweet dude
don't say mine ask i'm young okay what
else you got you all right
so a woman from new hampshire was on her
way home from a vacation over in europe
she was in italy and paris when she came
home from europe she noticed that when
she opened one of her three suitcases
that all of the gifts she had in her
third suitcase was gone and replaced
with dog food
and so now she's complaining to delta
about uh at some point during her flight
somebody from tsa or stole herself
uh it was
a leather jacket a few bags that she got
for family members during christmas
reports thousand bucks
all right well
my girl had all her [ __ ] stolen
tsa uh no uh she was on united and she
had all her bags stolen do you think
stolen or lost no well not only whether
do we know a stone they have the guy on
video
oh walking out and oh he went up to the
cart and pulled it off and uh he had
done it to other places like the baggage
claim cops you know had him and
everything else never heard back from
united never heard back from the cops
and this is three years ago never got
any money i mean what are they gonna do
dude well you know
usually they're supposed to give you
money yeah you know and and but nothing
nothing and trying to follow that
through good luck so if i'm united i'm
like hey dude get to your luggage faster
you know
well when the cops have their
well that's nice you lose a lot of [ __ ]
i know but if i'm a cop i'm like what do
you want me to do no but airlines are
supposed to go
supposed to have responsibility for that
the airline can guarantee once it's on
the
roundabout after that it's like hey doug
yeah get there faster yeah
i mean you're done yeah if i mean i'm
like
i mean and then you can
and you can like and they'll give you
like 300 bucks a bag or some [ __ ] it's
like that's why i love when celebrities
and comics complain about airlines on on
social media and united's like
cool don't fly united i tell you we
don't give a good i'm not flying spirit
anymore and the guy looks up like this
is a big line because what's that and he
goes i'm not flying spirit anymore
because i have to pay for my back and
the guy goes that's fine
yeah they're airlines i know they they
don't give a [ __ ]
they're not great i remember i remember
dalia was like [ __ ] out then that's
like cool yeah there's five years
old there's five airlines
we don't give a [ __ ] i've uh i've we're
up to money up there privately and i get
like points or i get like a free ticket
but i never capitalize on it i i just
i'm so bad at that like i think we're
going to collect three points yeah
okay cool i guess um
that's my favorite i'm not flying
southwest anymore southwest cool
if you said to me you got to fill out
this brochure and send it in and we'll
give you
100 oh no no i'll do you one better i'll
do one better hey do you want better my
girlfriend she's like what do you want
i'm like i don't need anything she's
like well if you're gonna buy someone
you buy and i want these lights for my
bronco so i want these three lights
these lights that go on top lights on
the side and lights for like this nerf
like fender bar sure the other two came
i put them on whatever they look great
the nerf bar came
they sent me the wrong part or whatever
it's this huge box and she goes
oh it didn't fit i got not unfit it's
like you know 900 likes something she
wasn't failing no she goes all right
well box it up and then just
there's a return note on there i go
that's never happening
what do you mean it's just we're just
going to take the l she goes what
it's just not going to work out she goes
no this year christmas if i i don't care
she goes are you [ __ ] me you won't
box this up and take a ups i go not a
chance not a chance matter of fact if it
was four thousand dollars i wouldn't do
that i have i really it's such a hassle
i gotta read get lost put it back in
they sent the wrong part it's like i
have small packages in the back of my
trunk right now i and all i have to do
is just drive to all i do i have to
drive down
and give them the code that i have my
phone i just can't do it it's just too
much
really i don't know man i'm [ __ ] the
worst with that you're all different i'm
already exhausted when you said that you
had a
how big is it it's a big bar
it's a big bar that goes on the front
and there's lights so i got it from
rough country a rough country you [ __ ]
me you [ __ ] me rough country you
[ __ ] me dude my christmas was [ __ ]
because of it you sent the wrong part it
doesn't fit on the bronco it's for a
four-door bronco mine's two-door it
doesn't fit yeah
so if anyone has a four door
if you want to stop by and pick it up
and then box it yourself you can have it
you'll do it and then you'll give it but
even then what and i don't want you in
my house i'll just leave it on the side
of the road you pick it up so what is
the bar it's like there's a is it a
light the light bar
it's like the front fender oh yeah it's
like a it has it came because i have the
the first edition was sasquatch package
it doesn't work for you it has four
lights on it it just doesn't okay
that
yeah but with four lights across the
front yeah it already has the nudge bar
it's a nudge bar with four lights oh i
see and so the one she got you is simply
too big
it just doesn't it does it doesn't fit
the two doors with the the first for the
four-door so it's not right there they
sent me the wrong [ __ ] one dude
it's that yeah they sent me the wrong
[ __ ] one now you gotta
take it easy take it easy now hold on
you gotta take those screws you gotta
put all that stuff back into the box and
send it back it came it came three weeks
late too [ __ ] you country all right
there's no way you can do it don't buy
rough country well don't be too much
hard on them oh yeah they didn't mean to
do that all right dude what do you mean
they didn't mean to do it they sent me
the wrong [ __ ] part yeah
yeah dude all right people make mistakes
they don't go out of business because
you oh they're going to be fine but also
make it right
you know what i'm saying because i'm not
going to pack it up the back country you
got to come in with the other one and
then just take the other one away yeah
just but i need a guide you want you
want someone to come pick it up i'm not
doing all that i mean i i i think you're
a bad person but i get it because i'm
the same exact way so i can't really say
much
i'll event i'll order clothes online
they send me a small
all right well that's what it is a piece
of my condition i'm just not gonna get
that we had a sponsor we had to do our
tuxedos and oh my god they're all brutal
what happened
they forced us to go to the shop to get
suited otherwise they went pace so me
and brian go in there i'm like
first of all getting us to go and get
fitted i can't believe we did that i
can't believe you though we were less
busy
less busy we go into chino they
i'll say their measurements in the chino
they took the measure and the suit shows
up dude it didn't it was way off one leg
was cutting off my circulation the other
leg was i couldn't believe it i was like
and i just i can't we even said to them
we go we i can't endorse it if that's
good i can't i can't have other people i
think they're out of business i think
they might be yeah they're definitely
[ __ ] on rodale anymore it's not a
good business model i mean it just
doesn't work dude it's a good business
model next thing i couldn't even close
the neck i'm like i can't believe we did
that
so you had to drive all the way to
beverly hills me and him drove down
there together gets fitted that [ __ ]
suit sat in my suit came two weeks later
we picked out the cloth remember we
picked out the claw i don't know how to
pick out clothes yeah i don't want to go
back and this is good this one's good
yeah that is what it is man
yeah damn what else you got jen yeah it
was it was hilarious
here we go
so this is an older one um
demi lovato oh my god
what's wrong with her now they they not
hurt they it's they what's wrong with
them now yes what's wrong with them uh
on this show
she was
they were
i guess doing a ghost encounter and the
ghost happened to be a woman named
carmen
who she's saying for in order to help
heal this ghost's trauma uh
yeah on the show the ghost gave her a
stand ovation apparently yeah apparently
about the trauma caused by men
uh and here later the star helps carmen
heal with a song as weird as it sounds
it goes like demi lovato's performance
and even offered a standing ovation
okay cool she's a talent though and
she's smoking about the same she can she
can [ __ ]
they can sing they can sing
it's really awkward and annoying but
okay yes it is
they they is fine hey there's fine yeah
they as fine as they they can sing yeah
they is talented she's just got some
just some team baggage
yeah yeah it's got all the baggage
united did not lose her baggage
they did not stays with her you lose her
baggage they gave her more package
yeah
fouchy
oh so she's telling us not to celebrate
new year's he's thank god for foul were
you seeing this one that
huh
felici
no no there's no foul okay
said
all right so this one's just uh i guess
joe biden did a white house call it's
called santa tracking whatever you know
so the people call in with their kids
and they talk to biden i would never do
that anyway so this guy
at the end of the call says
let's go brandon you know where gold
brandon started from
with the nascar driver when he won he
was doing you know whatever the
interview yeah and behind him they're
yelling [ __ ] joe biden and everybody
goes badly they're fired up they're
saying go brandon let's go
now it's hilarious but here's the
problem that poor nascar driver can't
get any main corporate sponsors now
because he's associated with let's go
brandon [ __ ] is that he's like hey man
i'm not even political he's like i'm not
political i want nothing to do with this
oh that sucks
he looks so innocent too brian [ __ ] joe
biden in the interview he's like let's
go brandon that's fantastic
and that's how this went so i i did it i
was a thing for discovery channel uh
where i had to hang out in a nascar
thing for a weekend it's intense yeah
there's there's there's they are not
they're not the most woke group i'll
tell you that much that's for damn sure
they're back then anyway this was
[ __ ] 15 years ago who's the black
driver now i was like i was like whoa
you guys hate everybody
there's a lot of them
i was like let me play the clip the
dad's getting some should we have a
wonderful day
yeah i hope you guys have a wonderful
christmas as well
merry christmas and let's go brandon
let's go brandon i agree hey by the way
where are you in oregon
he's just so old he doesn't where he
doesn't know right now the white house
brought it up he's like
no idea what's happening that was a
bummer i didn't like that don't say that
i mean he said it was a joke and it was
just
that's disrespectful
i don't like the guy right there yeah
it's still the president
i would never do that i would never do
that that's [ __ ] and he thought it
was going to be like an automated call
that he just leaves a message but he
actually got the president he's like oh
crap let's go brandon but if you got the
president he's an older man i don't know
man i you know i'm not yeah i don't want
anything he says i don't have anything
that's abiding but he thinks he could be
doing a better job yeah he was just
trying to do his thing i would never do
that then he hung up and it is a douchey
move it's still an older guy he's still
your president yeah like when do when it
become cool to hate on look look i don't
like biting at all but i'm not gonna
hate on well not only that you know he's
a man who's
he lived a long life who lost
he lost three children he lost his wife
he's been through a lot of tragedies the
other sons of crack yeah he's yep he's
not a complete [ __ ] he's just i don't
know he's actually a good dad i don't
agree with his politics no i don't care
i can separate him i like that
of my country he's the president i'm
going to be respectful as [ __ ] if i see
him because yeah i would never be i'm
calling him mr president yeah i'm going
to bow down
i didn't eat yeah brandon that that
those kind of cheap shots are that's
poor yeah it's vulgar yeah
[ __ ] off what else you got [ __ ] off
this right here i don't know how real
this is but that's pretty real is that
real
i've heard of this happening you listen
how many chicken [ __ ] tenders they
make
around the world you're gonna get ahead
every now and then i think it's
fantastic and i think it reminds you
that you eat a chicken yeah so someone i
also think chin would eat that chicken
right there not the entire well there's
certain beeks i would eat but not better
you eat the beak you would do it's deep
fried
you would dip that beacon sweet sour i
eat tails i had a pigeon's head i
grabbed that tight little [ __ ] beak i
sure did and i ate that [ __ ] head it
was cooked wait what was it tasted like
uh it tasted like liver it was in france
it was a live chicken not like that no
pigeon pigeon
no not a live pigeon it was a no it's a
forest fishing it's a squab you know
yeah anyway anyway yeah so here's what
they do at the restaurant
they present you with the head of the
pigeon
and they hold a napkin up so where they
hold the napkin up and then it's a
ritual and then you you take the beak
and you uh what are they the napkin
notes so people can't see you eat so
traditionally in france there was the mo
it's illegal now but the most one of the
most del the biggest delicacy was
there's a tiny bird it's about that big
it's like a hummingbird and there's a
season when it flies you know across
france and you catch it in a net
and what you do is you take you take the
bird you you basically you fatten it up
you get it super fat for like i don't
know three weeks you just feed it the
feeding feed yeah
so now it's all fat and [ __ ] dip and
sweet and you take it and the way you
kill it is you drown it in brandy okay i
know
it drowned in brandy it's pretty rough
and then you you roast it
and then you basically would take a
napkin or a sheet put it over your head
it's so weird so nobody could see you
doing this and then you [ __ ] eat them
whole no no i know when you're at your
goals uh get together you're meet and
greet for the skulls and you guys would
kill these guys
toss a a white sheet over your head
now hold on now did you guys use the
n-word no no no they're burning
crosstalk hold on hold on it's just you
put it let's say it's a large napkin
over your head and large napkins
the president of france the three-term
president of france that was his last
meal even though it was illegal he did
sure now as france do you mean new
orleans and was david dukes there do we
think i don't know i don't know was
david dukes there i don't know he's
creating an entire small bird hole even
though it's illegal is a racist act but
listen if you're putting a sheet over
your head that's where it gets that's
where it gets some type of symbolism
though maybe
so gin you you'd be fired up you'd give
them extra money if they did this to
your chicken tenders
no no i would have to know exactly how
it's done i don't be surprised i'll tell
you how stunned bird's head fell in the
deep fryer no if i was going to i just
can't believe that
but so this woman is claiming that but
kfc so this is in england it wasn't it
just she found the head in the box over
hot wings
and then uh kfc replied to it and
they're actually pretty funny about it
true that even the best laid plans can
on rare kids go awry and this incredibly
rare one
it's one we've taken incredibly
seriously already putting further
measures in place with our suppliers as
well as re
retraining our teams to prevent it
happen again that said it doesn't change
gabriel's gabrielle's experience so
we've reached out to her and she's now
accepted some free kfc on us and they
also said uh on twitter they're baffled
as to how a whole chicken hell was in
there and also it's the most generous
two-star review ever because they think
him two stars yeah yeah yeah yeah wow
but i mean
yeah that would freak me out kfc in
years i know think about the last years
i can't oh that reminds me uh i got a
a
air fryer yeah for a christmas exchange
and it is freaking fantastic game
changer my girl so dude i can have my
girl uh send me her recipe for her wings
yes
i'll make everything in there now i bet
you one yeah
chicken heads no it's true though an air
fryer
oh my god all the frozen girl cooked up
the wings that she made
yeah nice i had some i had some great
guys that i put in the fridge i had all
soggy and throw them away my girl was
like
yeah put them right in that [ __ ] oh you
can put them back in there oh yeah you
can do pizza dude
chicken nuggets they're dinosaur nuggets
shaped as dinosaurs they love them so
crispy make them in seven minutes ooh
they're nice yeah some of those chickens
oh and it's real quick yeah i mean like
seven minutes not too bad yeah yeah yeah
yeah
conventional oven now i don't the
commercial ovens are [ __ ] when i just
do a big air fryer is the oven now yeah
because it crisps it up too i mean
it tastes really good it's moist and
tender on the inside it's crispy and
crunchy on the outside it's just i don't
know i don't know you can [ __ ] with
other [ __ ] that's good yeah whole oven
you can cook steaks you cook everything
in there yeah there's like youtube
channels that are dedicated to like
different things you can cook
chicken wings
i gotta try that for sure my girl's
lemon pepper hot oh yeah she made the
lemon pepper goddamn she was making
everything yeah man oh yeah she did it
up
you're all colored up huh you mismatched
today colored up what do you mean that
sound weird you don't be tuned up
yep violet on huh when i told you not to
when i told you wear colors i didn't
mean violence i didn't even go gay hey
my girl got this for me sure yeah of
course she did this is not violet oh
those are cool though
those are new absolutely not because
they're worn off on the toe here i've
been wearing these for a long time yeah
man all right yeah but you got violet on
that's whatever excuse me sir or you
know what we'll call it
that's lavender lilac lavender lavender
yeah that's a nice color
with black dude sure
all right so this video has been going
around it's pretty vile right now so
delta airlines women passenger there's
not really much details on how this
started other than i guess this girl is
walking by a guy that didn't have his
mask on and then she told him to put it
on and then
this whole thing happened after well
what's up
nothing who would watch it it's a long
well not that long but
she she has her mask on yeah
oh it's underneath her nose yeah that's
frowned upon
no under her chin
i know her mask is off right now
what's under chin
that's an older dude too sit down karen
you get knocked out this old guy's gonna
put something heavy ready
mask up
now is that the trinity killer from
dexter
we'll check after
that
right there that's she who's she spent
on him yeah yeah i would have [ __ ]
lost him oh this guy got the coffee cart
rolling though that thing's heavy too
hot
where's his wife i think he's right next
to him
meanwhile hers is [ __ ] at her chin
this chick is out of her mind i don't
know i wish it was a she didn't have a
mask on it i wish there was a big girl
on the flight to [ __ ] her up yeah
someone
but the whole mass covet stuff gives
people this weird like power now like
weird people that have never had power
before
[Music]
the cops had
were ready for her when they uh when
that flight had landed yeah she's [ __ ]
yeah she should be fine
totally but also like to be that
aggressive oh no she'll about people
like she'll get sued handcuffed hand it
off to the fbi that's going to cost her
a lot of money that's like it's in the
air it's a federal whatever offense or
something yeah it's crazier she's going
to not be able to fly the airline it's
going to cost her a [ __ ] she's going to
pay a fine he's going to sue her she's
going to pay a lot of money that's a dom
stop calling her karen which
is it
you said [ __ ] then she went off on it
but also like you know people say that
when they take airlines they a lot of
times they'll take ambien or something
and they're not in the same frame of
mind you've heard this before right from
other people
she can kiss me i know
but i wonder if that's just she'll say
that he's a strong man for taking that
spirit i know dude that's the strongest
scratch
there's not much you can do as a man
i would look at my girlfriend
i know right yeah i can't do that i
can't do it and kill her i can't if i
get up and knock her the [ __ ] out what
am i going to do i'm really in trouble
then yeah you know you can't win that
you got to just take you got to eat all
the dicks for a while mm-hmm
she's [ __ ] now because her name's out
and her instagram handles that yeah i
think she deleted or oh people are
lighting her up lighten
yeah you seem to do that to the wrong
person get beat up oh yeah that's what
they they need because because she's
lucky she caught him she should have
been there that'll knock her the [ __ ]
out that's what i'm saying yeah
this looks pretty crazy um so this guy
is
a real estate agent guy who's on
instagram kind of flaunts his riches and
stuff like that but apparently he's also
a serial killer
fantastic he would drive at night and
then walk up to homeless people and just
shoot him in the face yeah so one person
survived i think a few others died or
something like that
and he also looks a little bit like
a singer during no
singer
damn it what happened now they covered
his face
yeah trey songz no am i tripping oh no
you're tripping yeah you might be
tripping on that job i see a little bit
all right anyways
this is an instagram handle that's an
evil dude
yeah
oh look at it and of course people are
crypto
that that was outside [ __ ] last time no
no yeah but he does i guess in the in
the past he did someone said will you be
able to drive this in prison
they're all comments about that stuff
just one of those guys yeah murderer
rotten prison
some people are just crazy yeah like
you're so he was like real real he's
like doing well in real estate serial
killer by night yeah got off on killing
yeah that's what he gets off on damn
what a weird person he's [ __ ] let me
see more pictures of him i see the rest
of his i like seeing what he's more like
real estate stuff on here
oh there's one he was slang in here you
would never expect right here what he
says guys good evening making another
short video for you about real estate
this one is going to be dedicated i
didn't expect that accident the buyers
buying process the very first thing that
you want to take care when you're
planning on buying a home is to make
sure that you know what amount you know
how much property can you acquire and
that the way that you he seems like such
a nice guy you would never expect a
[ __ ] he looks like a penny hardaway
yeah
together
oh okay now we have a great song no the
other picture whatever so it's alleged
that these happens just to make sure
legend the cops put two and two together
yeah they follow his license plate and
everything so you just you run up and
shoot him in the face and then run off
right homeless people yeah jesus christ
i've heard about that happening to
people with bats would hit homeless
people it's something that that's a way
to kill people without feeling like
you're actually killing regular human
beings homeless yeah [ __ ] up people
who get off yeah he's [ __ ] causing
pain
um this is just a quick one jay-z said
he would be unbeatable in versus no he's
asked the question i need to beat the
[ __ ] at him
um hold on i'll play this real quick
your best hits versus another artist's
best hits kind of light them up you're
on stage and yeah you you guys go back
and forth
you mean if they were
little wayne would really light him up
he's saying i think this is for like a
freestyle battle though
i need this i ain't allowed no
disrespect everyone's amazing
and done what they've done
no one just stand on that stage
i'm just telling you guys he's got some
i think
there's not a chance in hell that anyone
can stand on that stage from before i
don't know how long it is two hours
two hours
right
basically as we said and then future
said he could
and then people were clowning on future
the future wouldn't be my goat yeah yeah
that's not my first picture kanye or
drake could do it definitely kanye kanye
100 could do it
and they're also saying lil wayne and
lil wayne wayne lewin's another one yeah
i guess you guys haven't heard of eminem
yeah i mean it'll be great too yeah
that's fair
yeah maybe remember that heartwarming
story we talked about just before
christmas how the home alone house is
going to be
rented out for airbnb's girlfriend woof
yes this guy hits so he was the one that
was in charge of all that he was in
charge now he was arrested for
apparently allegedly hitting his chick
and buzz is not keto no buzzers look the
exact same and the reason is because
they went to like you know one of those
comic-con things signing events so they
went to a bar afterwards he was drinking
this is what his girl says and then two
girls went up to ask for autograph pic
autographed picture and then this girl
gave her gave him or gave the girls two
pre-autographed pictures sure weird he
said those in i know but he said that
you got pissed off because she didn't
charge them for oh
and then she went off he went off as his
girlfriend buzz looks like uh white mike
if you have eating brownies
dude he does look a little like white
you're welcome
yeah mike turner
turner it might be turner comedy i mean
i think it's turner comedy white mike
he's a token white guy yeah that's why
he dates a black girl he's like he has
that swag he's great he's a break
die hard oh i know mike yeah yeah yeah
yeah great
mike oh that's
yeah that's a good one that's a good one
yeah there you go there you go
i mean that's buzz that is
the gift so who is this buzz guy i don't
know who this book is from home alone
remember the guy the bully brothers
you've seen humble right yeah yeah have
you seen it i have but it's so long ago
christmas though you know remember this
kid
oh yeah yeah
buzz's girlfriend
here's the pet tarantula yeah well he
did lose a lot of weight look at this
picture
if it loads he lost a lot of assistance
god life is [ __ ] don't get covered
daddy yeah it's tough god dawg
all right yeah
you know
yeah yeah this is pretty interesting
spiderway spiderweight spiderman no way
home is sony's highest grossing movie
ever now this is a good thing because
this shows you that people aren't scared
to go out of the house
yeah so it shows you that theaters are
back i took my son to sing i took both
kids and my girl to sing too yesterday
how was it great [ __ ] movie it looks
packed packed that movie amc was packed
and counted that's awesome yeah yeah but
it's also tom holland every movie he's
been in so far has just been killing it
he's so good yeah [ __ ] him people say
that's like the best spider-man too my
favorite spider-man family yeah it's
nice
toby but whatever totally my favorite
too i i think he's really good and he's
the first he kind of likes at the bar
but i wouldn't say he's the best who's
the best tom holland i haven't seen this
one if toby had the right storyline he
could have been it's just like a matter
of fact i still think the spider versus
the best spider-man oh oh yeah
i found toby
mcguire to be a little bit lacking in
charisma
in
that i just love the way they did that
it's like super cartoonish you know like
you know comical when they did the first
one so i like yeah i don't like when it
gets too sweet yeah like they're comic
book guys man but then they didn't like
the batman the real no no no i hate that
[ __ ]
yeah i don't like the the one we're like
good for you and i like arnold
schwarzenegger's mr freeze oh yeah i
like jim carrey is the rhythm
yeah that's what they are man i made
real life yeah like joaquin thinks the
gray and the joker i didn't i don't need
to know his [ __ ] mental health yeah
yeah yeah that that was not a that was
not a batman movie yeah it was so
serious yeah it's fantastic but yeah
jesus christ that movie did really good
though yeah yeah [ __ ] yeah you want to
oscar for it dude yeah oh why you do
that that's the last one just for fun
guys though dude it's for chappelle you
would you had a real chance jojo is like
chappelle is one of the biggest his
biggest questions
yeah oh really
engaged
to a nice-looking dude like a guy who's
not as good looking at chapel nope small
look at her there thank you guys smoking
um he has those dior cakes on top
who is this guy
do you know about him he's like a fellow
actor i think he's an actor on the save
by the bell reboot okay there you go all
right
looks very innocent nice dude
that's like then back in the day i'm
sure
seems like at least she's more recent oh
i don't know
it could have been you she's i know
look at her all curved up and stuff yep
no it's just me
hey she was the one that went on
instagram live and accidentally showed
her tit remember we had that at his
current event yeah wow now can she can
she don't post that picture though you
know i know wait go back that one don't
look at that she's like well she's
probably giving that is that to the pop
no that's gotta be her homie now him now
he looks um she's um
where from boston
she sings that song um
let it rain
oops she hasn't done a hit in a hot
second yeah she was stuck in a really
weird uh yeah whatever she just said
every time i try to tell them
i'm not trying to how many people at
shitty contracts still put out hits you
know she couldn't legally yeah
you're kind
i'm digging this because it reminds me
of arizona i'm not crazy i'm kind of
jealous i'm not crazy where'd you get it
what where'd you get it it's double rl
i don't know what that is yeah
tits
[Laughter]
are they real
yeah real nice yeah
she's tiny too right she's got to be
short short yeah she's very sexy i like
that kind of she's she's kind of making
a comeback for no apparent reason yeah
right
what like we're talking about her all
the time i mean i know chappelle likes
her but
she's in the news model she's she's
she's got a full tour coming off right
now [ __ ] yeah dude she's got a tour
she's got a full tour is it an arena
tour
no
it's not an arena tour but hey it's a
tour what's her anybody what's a recent
song
um
i'm gonna be that girl when you always
have them
jojo man just crashing it
all right guys
fort lauderdale december 3rd january 1st
that's this thursday friday saturday
with the thick crew fort lauderdale
florida and then los angeles hollywood
improv the crew is back january 5th one
night only one show only if you didn't
get tickets for last week's show this is
it it will sell out guaranteed so get
tickets right now while you list this
tickets at fatkz.com it's job and
friends hollywood improv with a very
special guest you guys are going to love
then rally north carolina is january 6th
through january 8th and then fight
companion is january 22nd with christa
stefano
and uh if you're below the belt listener
audio stays exactly the same your boy
owns rss feed for that there'll just be
a new graphics called the shop show now
and you can watch it every week uh
including with food truck and calabash
fight campaign on think boy youtube only
so subscribe now thick boy with three
c's oklahoma city i'll see you this
weekend thursday on your throat huh shut
up
break down comedy club december 30th
31st and january 1st
and then salt lake city utah wise guys
january 6th 7th and 8th i'll see you
there
uh spokane i had to i'll be out with
brendan on these uh tour dates in
january and then february 25th through
26th i'll be in kansas city missouri at
the comedy club of kansas city and as
always uh merch and then always uh oh
listen to my podcast chappelle's world
as well all right guys love you boom